let's go to voicemail the egg man wrote
in the egg man had some thoughts about
everything that's going on of course the
voicemail number is two one nine to
david p the egg man called in not wrote
in and here's what he had to say it is
in discussing what a hypocrite Trump is
already and all the usual suspects he
lined up for his transition team the
guys that I work with that the
low-information voters have voted for
Trump's yeah they hear this story right
now they don't even know any of those
names it means nothing to them they
don't even know what a transition team
is they have no clue of any of this
stuff all they know is Trump Trump Trump
yeah they don't care all the nuances in
all of the hypocrisy mean nothing to
these people they don't even understand
you're talking to two liberals on your
show that understandest but that some
people may be here blah blah blah blah
blah come from from from truck that's it
they don't care yep it's very scary
couldn't say it better myself we talked
about the obvious hypocrisy of Trump
saying hey I'm not the Washington guy
I'm running an outsider candidate it's
gonna be non-establishment and then
within hours of becoming president elect
he hires all the same Republican
lobbyist and at nine verizon lobbyists
that everybody else hires but a lot of
his supporters have no clue what the
hell is going on transition team
lobbyists what I don't know what's going
on I just voted for Trump is gonna make
America great again spot on by the
eggman on the bonus show today robots
could replace two-thirds of all workers
in the developing world in the
developing world I've got a couple of
really funny stories and and some that
are a little bit more disturbing from
over the weekend I think people will
really like today's bonus show sign up
support independent media david
pakman.com slash membership